Професія учителя у Німеччині належить до найбільш шанованих і добре оплачуваних.
Окрім цих переваг, учителювання приваблює багатьох німців соціальною захищеністю,
гнучким робочим графіком і можливістю добре поєднувати професійне та особисте життя.
З іншого боку, німецькі вчителі часто скаржаться на синдром вигорання і стресовість професії:
їм чи не щодня доводиться мати справу з конфліктними ситуаціями і годинами перебувати у дуже шумному середовищі. Як це оплачується?
За даними Організації економічного співробітництва й розвитку (OECD), учителі в Німеччині -  серед найкраще оплачуваних педагогів країн Євросоюзу.
Так, шкільний учитель старших класів із 15-річним досвідом роботи - у ФРН в середньому заробляє майже 89 тисяч доларів на рік.
Вищі зарплати - лише у його колег з Люксембургу.
До найкраще оплачуваних належать також учителі у Нідерландах, Ірландії, Данії та Австрії.
А ось учителі старших класів із 15-річним стажем із Чехії, Угорщини і Словаччини заробляють у кілька разів менше.
У вчителів початкових класів з багаторічним досвідом рівень зарплат хоча й дещо нижчий, однак співвідношення зберігається -
німецькі педагоги і в цьому європейському рейтингу також на другому місці.
На те, скільки заробляють німецькі учителі, впливає низка факторів.
Приміром, тип школи, де викладає педагог – як-от загальна, реальна школа або гімназія;
федеральна земля, у якій працює учитель;
сімейний стан – адже він впливає на клас оподаткування;
досвід у професії та нарешті - форма працевлаштування.
Усіх учителів у Німеччині за статусом фактично можна поділити на три групи - держслужбовці, наймані працівники та учителі без педагогічної освіти,
які прийшли з інших професій. Найбільша (і найбільш привілейована) група вчителів - держслужбовці.
Вони мають найкращий соціальний захист і підвищені пенсії, а їхня зарплата після усіх відрахувань не надто відрізняється від суми брутто.
Педагоги-наймані працівники мусять відраховувати приблизно 20% різноманітних внесків.
Найнижчі ставки й заробітки – у третьої категорії – учителів без педагогічної освіти й досвіду.
Таких фахівців останніми роками активно переманюють до шкіл із галузей природничих і технічних наук,
адже учителів математики, інформатики, фізики, хімії, біології у німецьких школах критично не вистачає.
Різниця у зарплатах між цими трьома категоріями може сягати десятків тисяч євро за рік.
Стати державним службовцем може тільки учитель із німецьким громадянством.
Середнє робоче навантаження німецького учителя - 40 годин на тиждень.
30 із них зазвичай - уроки, ще 10 - підготовка до занять і перевірка письмових робіт.
Утім, часто це навантаження - значно більше.
Місячні ставки варіюються, у середньому від трьох до п’яти тисяч євро брутто.
На розмір ставок впливають: досвід роботи, кваліфікація і навіть клас викладання –
зазвичай учителі старших класів зароблять більше, ніж початкових (хоча саме педагогів початкових класів у німецьких школах бракує найбільше).
Ще одна особливість німецьких учителів - як правило, вони викладають не один, а щонайменше два предмети.
Комбінації можуть бути різними, приміром, географія і мистецтво, або математика і література.
Іноземцям, які хочуть викладати у німецькій школі, доведеться підтверджувати диплом і довчатися, щоби викладати ще один предмет.
До речі, у німецьких школах, як і в українських - більше викладачів-жінок: у початкових школах їх маже 90%, а в гімназіях - 60.
У Німеччині немає загальнодержавних ставок – тарифні сітки за вчительську працю визначаються на рівні федеральних земель.
Так, учитель гімназії з найменшим досвідом найкраще зароблятиме у землях Баварія, Баден-Вюртемберг і Північний Рейн-Вестфалія -
понад 5 з половиною тисяч євро на місяць.
Найменше - у Мекленбурзі-Передній Померанії та Берліні - близько 4-ох тисяч євро.
Загалом же, по всій Німеччині учителям старших класів, особливо у гімназіях, платять більше, ніж педагогам початкової школи.
На вищі ставки можуть розраховувати і вчителі, які беруть класне керівництво.
А ще німецьким учителям повністю оплачують канікули – це 12-13 тижнів у рік!
Частину канікул педагоги витрачають на відпустку, решту - на підготовку до уроків і підвищення кваліфікації.
Педагогів у Німеччині готують "фаххохшуле" - спеціалізовані вищі школи - та університети.
Перші готують готують учителів для початкової і середньої школи, останні - для гімназій. Навчання триває зазвичай 6 семестрів.
Майбутньому педагогу належить скласти два державні іспити.
Між ними, як правило, проходить практика у школах - вона триває приблизно півтора року.
За даними Німецької спілки учителів, Німеччині наразі не вистачає десятків тисяч учителів.
Так, лише у федеральній землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія дефіцит становить 4 тисячі педагогів.
Велика частка - учителі природничих спеціальностей, німецької мови та музики.